When you're in a studio somewhere on
Earth, you're going to see that there
are some slip-ups when they're trying to
remember this whole delay thing. And we
have adjusted the fan speed. We'll take
a thumbs up if you're happy with it.
Oh, but Copy thumbs
>> Oh, we got a space.
They're giving thumbs up, and now he's
like, "Hey, this guy." Superlative
thumbs up.
>> Oh, man. She asks for a thumbs [music]
up, and he does it immediately.
This is just damning evidence right
here. They are just having a regular
conversation. He's not giving a thumbs
up for any other reason except to answer
this [music] lady. We are 3 minutes out
from an on-time start, and we have
adjusted the fan speed. We'll take a
thumbs up if you're happy with it.
Copy thumbs up.
The lady even said, "Copy thumbs
[laughter] up." Even
>> Copy thumbs up.
Wow, it happened when they were talking
to Trump as well. And then Trump
actually addresses it. He's like, "Oh,
we got a 9-second delay or whatever."
Check this out. Administrator Alex Azar,
just get a quick com check. Make sure
you guys are still on the line and we
didn't have a uh handover.
I am. Yes, I am. We're on the line and
[music] we didn't have a uh handover.
I am. Yes.
>> You hear how quick Trump [music]
responded, right? We just wanted to add
that, you know, as soon as he finishes
the sentence, "I am." Right away.
Listen. Check. Make sure you guys are
still on the line and we didn't have a
uh handover.
I am. Yes, I am. That was not 9 seconds.
Now, listen to Trump try and I don't
know what he's doing. He's He can't
cover it up because he's literally
giving himself away here. Uh yeah, I
think we might have gotten cut off. It
is a long distance. It's a long ways.
The reception's been great. There's a
little bit of about a 9-second delay,
but uh A little bit of a 9-second delay.
You should have used a landline like
Nixon. It would have went a lot better.
>> [music]